i
[Música]
olivia squatrito
[Aplausos]
hay frases que tienen la capacidad de
fuerte los pelos de punta
pruébalo es muy sano mañana empiezas es
cuál es el solo un pinchacito
cuando tienes 11 años lo más terrorífico
que puedes escuchar es este año vas a
hacer el pp
es el oficial de inglés que tiene mezcla
si queremos entrar en un buen instituto
aquí en europa y todo esclavos entrar en
un buen grupo no así que ahora sí
aparece ese examen bien es muy grande
para nosotros y para nuestros profes que
nos lleva preparando todo el año
el examen los dos días y la última parte
es legal te meten en una habitación con
un desconocido un inglés que llega de
cambridge y tienes que con tal y cual es
parte de tenerle que pueda ser más
terrorífico de eso
llega el momento el agua te enseña una
foto que escoge al azar y tú tienes que
escribir se lo abierto que está
una familia embarcando en un aeropuerto
tenéis que saber que aunque hubiese
aprendido a andar
yo había cogido varios aviones mi
familia está repartida entre cuatro
países y tres ciudades así que seguro me
toca ser a menudo es viajar
según te mente los mejores cuestiones en
cada terminal de barajas
sé que antes hay registro tengo que
hacer provisiones de valor hechas con
sal y azúcar porque en materia las hay y
si cantidad antes de llegar al cuarto es
de ponerme es que si tienes japoneses
que tienen como dedos porque al cual es
de seguridad es ser muchas gracias y
entonces aunque pita pasar por el
control primaria mucho menos
una foto del aeropuerto en la foto
superfamilia y no podía cree mi suerte
tome aire pero allí estaba la voz de mi
cabeza me decía tienes que hacerlo bien
aquí entra no puedes fracasar y difusos
hubo nervios a y pum de repente y de
loco lado de como si decía la palabra
maleta maleta tengo haber escuchado esa
palabra por lo menos un millón de veces
y justo el examen se me olvidaba empecé
vean pues se giró llevando esa cosa con
ruedas donde potes tu ropa y tus zapatos
un desastre y cuanto más pensaba en que
estaba fracasando peor lo hacía llevaba
todo daño extiende para esto ahora si
vas dedicados a la gramática y el
vocabulario y justo el día del examen me
pasaba esto salir de la habitación
llorando todos los del examen me había
salido muy bien esto es un ejercicio
pero aún así yo sólo podía pensar en la
dichosa abuelita y lo pasé fatal todo el
día
cómo se pasó les gustó me puso a pensar
me di cuenta de que el fracaso siempre
va a estar ahí a la vuelta de la esquina
y cuando menos te lo esperas que tenía
que aprender para sacar el mejor
pero es que hay un problema y es que la
mayor parte del tiempo la pasó en el
colegio y el colegio no te enseñan a
fracasar y estás muy curioso porque cada
día en el colegio que ponen delante sus
situaciones que parecen haber sido
diseñadas específicamente para que
fracases exhalar es como el pp una
competición constante entre compañeros
fue hecho de clases en escoger al sí que
tenga capacidad para hacerlo
por ejemplo este mes es tenido que
rellenar los institutos la solicitud
para instituto público ya podían escoger
entre bilingüe en francés o el alemán
vamos haber aprendido en estaba alemania
el año pasado una vez existió dedicarle
seis años de mi vida
en fin que en el colegio ancho después
vamos a equivocarnos y experimentar el
fracaso pero aquí me dice sí a fracasar
a estos adultos se llama una paradoja
pero por qué colegio si a fracasar
porque comete tres errores
uno se centra en el éxito en el colegio
desde pequeños aprendemos que lo más
importante es sacar sobresalientes no
equivocarnos tener razón el profesor
siempre tiene razón y el fracaso no es
una opción todo enfoque está en tener
éxito pero está demasiado seguro de la
breve opinión puede ser peligroso nos
impide ser elásticos y tened en cuenta
opciones que pueden es incluso mejores
y si queremos hacer con cheniere es
decir una generación dispuesta a cambiar
y a mejorar las cosas tenemos que tener
en cuenta que el fracaso ser parte del
proceso es que ningún colegio sería
fracasar
mons y light 1 el wing college que en
eeuu al defensor de matemáticas en
wahlburgers que era un 5% de su nota a
la calidad de fracaso los segundos
tienen canalizar sus errores les tienen
que se equivocaron que aprendieron de
ellos esto nos lleva a arriesgarse más y
ser más creativos pero en todas las más
colegios y doy cuenta es aceptar sin
embargo hay un sitio donde si se centra
en el fracaso sabéis cuál es la nasa en
la masa tiene un nicho no existe un
problema que no se pueda esperar y toda
la formación de nuestro nautas se basa
en bici para errores
es un culto al fracaso que lleva al
éxito y al revés como suele ser en el
colegio
él sufría viajar por el espacio y
austria el astronauta chris hatley turno
con el casco y si quedó así durante unos
minutos cualquier otra persona
ambientado en pánico pero él no por qué
porque ya habían dicho y cosas como esta
falla en pasar y él sabía cómo
resolverlas porque el cuál no tipo de
errores porque no había excusas que
seguramente va pasen así bueno así entró
en pánico cuando me equivoco este veto
les ha servido a colocar a personas en
la luna no crees que pudiese darle a mí
para llegar por lo menos hasta la
universidad
2 el colegio en sí a fracasar porque es
un sistema individual la mayoría de las
veces nuestro miedo a fracasar y está
unido que la preocupación sobre qué
piensan los demás de nosotros siempre
estamos pendientes de que tienen los
demás o de qué hacer relación como es un
sueño con nuestro objetivo y son los
expertos y son mejores y perdemos el
foco importante que es dar cada uno en
cada ocasión lo mejor de sí mismo pero
es lógico que pensamos así porque en el
colegio desde el primer día de la
competición constante uno contra uno
deberíamos trabajar más en equipo
deberían existir más que deseamos a
disfrutar las victorias de los demás
una vez si los adultos capaces de
transformar su trabajo en su misión el
centro que hacen para llegar a fin de
mes algo que hacen para aportar los
demás son mejores en su trabajo por eso
creo que el colegio debería dedicar más
debería dedicar más cosas en las que dar
un aporte a todo lo que es a toda clase
y no sólo ha sufrido el siguiente
tener una misión nos hace muy fuertes
casi invencibles está bien
amstrong unidad
cuando tenía seis años el mejor amigo de
taller se enfermó el diagnosticado
síndrome de usher una enfermedad
degenerativa muscular y taller decidió
que ya salgo para ayudar le habían ido
tres pues ya si conseguían portadas
deportivas conseguían sponsors y se
puede investigar para saber que sabía
hacer él pero con seis años indicó que
también se era caminar y correr
así que decidió que quería caminar lo
más lejos posible crezca la cima de la
montaña
la empresa para de que la entrada pero
al principio su padre quería quitarme de
la cabeza pensaba que era imposible que
universitarias consiguiera un esposo por
escalar
así como yo colorido de su casa él le
dijo a tyler venga vamos a entrenar y
salió y se puede combinar rapidísimo
casi corriendo pensaba con su cansaría
trail a pilar ya rendirse pero al día
siguiente con el paro había del trabajo
en esta batalla dispuestos habido
entrenando entrenó hoy entreno y en poco
tiempo consigue escalar el monte más
alto de los eeuu el monte whitney
taller no se paró ahí 218 más escalar
montañas y superar récords
has cuidado el aconcagua el kilimanjaro
y ahora se están quedando para escalar
el everest
tales siempre dice que acaba de sufrir
agujetas voy a centrarse piensa en su
misión ayudar a su amigo los otros niños
como él su misión es la energía y le
ayuda a no fracasar
y por último
el colegio ansía fracasar porque no
existe la asignatura felicidad
si son enseñadas tenemos felices
fracasaríamos mejor hoy explicó
el caso es que vale éxito que ha
sucedido hasta ahora el que tiene
nuestros padres éxito y wallace
felicidad siempre se ha dicho primero
estudias fuese de mucho así conseguirás
entrar con una buena universidad si
responsable pues si es un buen trabajo
ya sea máximo pues si es un buen puesto
y sólo entonces serás feliz pero ya los
psicólogos decidieron cuestiones es que
es este esquema
porque si fuera cierto no existirían por
ejemplo tenemos deprimidos en jay lonja
al mar o personas infelices con puestos
de trabajo muy importantes
y supone como se diga el top como es que
no son felices
seguían cuenta de que este esquema no
funciona porque el cerebro aves que era
un desafío que le motive seguros a días
de esquí gótico del dolor entre un buen
colegio un instituto mejor recuerdo de
superación el colegio no sea éste ya no
sabe qué hacer al tras falta de desafíos
y se primero se desanima
si la felicidad está otro lado del éxito
tu cerebro nunca conseguirá llegar ella
siendo después toda felicidad un poco
más allá lo necesitamos aquí y ahora
porque fijaos los expertos ecología
positiva tanto de puente que hay un
escriba que funcionaría muchísimo mejor
fue el castigo al éxito un cerebro
optimista y positiva funciona mucho
mejor que un negativo o bajo estrés
las personas felices afrontan mejor
desafíos lo lleva la ventaja de
felicidad y tiene que ver con la
sustancia del cerebro
como estudiar está bajo estrés una parte
del cerebro la medida de la energía otra
la cusa prefrontal que se incubó que
podamos resolver problemas
en cambio cual seremos esencia de
felicidad por cerebro segrega una
sustancia llamada dopamina la familia
dice que su culpa no sobre la felicidad
es también activa de la formaliza g
musical feliz aprende más rápido y es
más que puede utilizar lo que sabe la
felicidad aumenta la creatividad su
energía inteligencia matemática nos
parece clave estuviera afrontado en
examen
por eso creo que en el colegio debería
dedicar nuestro tiempo a las matemáticas
o el inglés también así que nos hace más
felices y cómo se hace eso os
preguntaréis pues entramos en la verdad
sea más feliz es muy diferente entrenar
a cualquier otro músculo en el gimnasio
porque el cerebro es plástico es decir
si cambias tus hábitos podés cambiar la
manera de caer acciona o mejora su
funcionamiento
es tres psicólogos estudiando muchísimo
tiempo hábitos y se han dado cuenta de
que hay unos súper sencillos capaces de
aumentar la felicidad y de optimismo
escribir cada noche durante veintiún
días tres cosas por las que se
agradecido
mitad minutos al día hacia alimentos
ejercicio diarios y de un diario
unos estudios alucinantes han demostrado
que hacer una o más de estas cosas
durante 21 días cambió enormemente a
actitud de las personas y que esta
actitud dice que se comporta mejor ante
un desafío
por lo tanto si consigues el feliz de
fracaso saldrás mejores en el caso
en definitiva que si quieren esta casa
el colegio no a su abogado ya poder
hacerlo así que a cuestionó stewart y
por ahora esto es con esto se ve fracaso
1 este caso no me define para muchos
efectos y definir qué tipo de persona
eres estoy enseña que el fracaso es algo
malo algo que hay que evitar
allí está el que está de este caso si un
chiquito como fracasado me condenó a
seguir fracasando
en el colegio a menudo se cree etiquetas
de listo la del burro y enseguida te
hace sentir fracasado
si aprendes que no quiero fracasar
porque obviamente no quiere etiquetar el
burro
pero fuera del colegio también quedamos
en esto cuando alguien me sale algo o
dice algo mal enseguida decimos no seas
tonto
pero que recuerda una cosa muy
importante equivocarse tiene que ver con
hacer algo mal lo conservo
2 este caso es como tu pasión
una disuasión es esta cultura japonesa y
en esta cultura existe un concepto
llamado el liquigás el kiwi es la razón
por la que te levantas un salto cada día
a la cama esa pasión que te hace ser una
persona feliz
si no tienes una razón por qué
adelantarte el 3 modo cada día para los
japoneses es como estar muerto funciona
así
encuentra tu hija y no es nada fácil
para eso tienes que probar muchas cosas
nuevas y diferentes porque se va
simplemente te gusta te interesa un poco
será muy difícil que se llega a ser
feliz
por si cambia o te apasiona entonces sí
que será lo que te haga feliz y lo que
te motiva
pero contra super pasiones tampoco es
nada fácil algunos tienen muchas su
material estaban desde pequeños para la
mayoría tenemos que buscar muchas cosas
y el problema es que pasamos nuestro
tiempo ligados a las mismas asignaturas
no probamos instrumentamos haciendo
cosas nuevas
y luego llega un momento que hacemos que
nos damos cuenta de que no es algo que
queremos hacer
es curioso justo había fracasado así que
me voy a experimentar y la falta de
experimentación es lo que te impide
encontrar tu visión de gb
así que si algún día prueba según evo y
no te gusta no es bueno en ello
rivas como un fracaso
vívelo con lo que puede estar algo más
titulice está como si estás más cerca de
encontrar todo lo que te apasiona
eso es un macarra la mayoría de las
veces había fracasar el fracaso de dos
efectos o nunca vas solo fue una parte
de más desgasta caras convencionales en
las películas su mejor amigo es el miedo
el negro es muy amable y educado dice
cosas como vas a hacerlo mal para esto
sirves conservadas dinero
pero no me dejarán los macarras así
estuvimos aclara que ellos
por ejemplo sin miedo te dice vas a
hacerlo mal para esto sirve es tienes
que decirle sí y qué
siempre el ají mejor que tú pero eso da
igual dice da miedo si yo te hice a
estos lugares no es el mejor tú tienes
que decirle me da igual porque estoy
pasando tipo
4 este caso es gasolina cada uno había
dentro de la burbuja la llama la zona de
confort dentro todo esté separado todo
el seguro y todo está controlado
pero hay dos opciones salir de ella
viviera superarte y de aventuras o
quedarte dentro con la vida aburrida
pero segura
y como si sale a base de fracasar
sobre un nuevo es lo que quieres es ir a
una selva empieza a caminar solicitud
zona de confort y te das cuenta de que
la maleza te impide seguir caminando
hacia el cazador pero sabes la próxima
vez lo que quieres hacer es tener un
machete así puedes ir andando ese
próximo obstáculo
has avanzado un poco más allá
date prisa fracasar es lo que te da
energía lo que te ayuda a seguir tus
sueños
no sé cómo será el futuro no tengo ni
idea de que estudiaré a la que me
dedicaré lo que sí que sé es que este
caso va a formar parte sí o sí el
proceso
o sea bueno que dijo una vez lo
intentaste fracasaste da igual intento
de otra vez y fracasa mejor
si es capaz de ver a esta casa con y
mejor al profesor volvemos amigos para
que me da libertad de hacer lo que yo
quiera
y sobre todo centrarme en lo que pienso
yo de qué versión es acabar
sobresaliente si sé que no es forzado
porque este sistema si suspende si yo sé
que dado el máximo
creo que si consigo mantenerme feliz en
medio de los fracasos será como tener un
superpoder
lo bueno es que depende de mí está en él
y leyó el libro de víctor frankl impactó
mucho el hombre en busca de sentido
cuánta experiencia en un campo de
concentración ella dice que tú eres
único mundo tus sentimientos puede
cambiar lo que piensas
creo que eso es lo que nos hace grandes
a los seres humanos
así que si algún día fracasas recuerdas
en forma de estrellas
aceptar fracaso aprende de él y sigue
avanzando
y recuerda si alguna y fracasas te
pregunto qué tienes que hacer no es que
quieres hacer sino fui a fracasar me
preguntes si quieres hacer aunque
fracase gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]